para hidrogenar un alqueno necesitas gas
hidrógeno y un catalizador metálico algo
como platino o paladio o níquel Y hay
muchos más pero estos son los más usados
lo que pasa es que esos dos hidrógenos
del gas hidrógeno se agregan a través
del doble enlace y se añaden en el mismo
lado donde estaba el doble enlace por lo
que es una adición sin
veamos por qué esta es una adición sin
de hidrógenos tenemos nuestro
catalizador metálico por
aquí continuemos dibujando nuestro
catalizador metálico plano Y estos
metales son seleccionados porque
absorben muy bien el hidrógeno lo que
significa que si
burbujea gas
hidrógeno a lo largo el hidrógeno será
absorbido por la superficie del
catalizador metálico así y luego viene
tu alqueno y tu alqueno también es plano
cierto la porción de la molécula que
contiene el doble
enlace estos dos carbonos este carbono y
este carbono tienen hibridación
sp2 lo que significa que la
estereoquímica alrededor de esos dos
carbonos será plana esta porción de la
molécula es plana tienes algo plano
aproximándose a algo que también es
plano la única forma en la que esos
hidrógenos pueden añadirse es
añadiéndolo en el mismo lado cierto este
carbono y este carbono si añades este
hidrógeno al carbono de la izquierda y
añades este hidrógeno al carbono de la
derecha y luego continúas dibujando el
resto de los enlaces esto ahora sería
una cuña y luego líneas a trazos y luego
esto sería una cuña y luego líneas a
trazos puedes ver que esos dos
hidrógenos se han añadido al mismo lado
estos dos hidrógenos
son estos dos hidrógenos para nuestra
adición sin nota que también estamos
yendo de una hibridación st2 a una
hibridación sp3 aquí en la derecha
tenemos que pensar en estereoquímica
para esta reacción y para tus productos
también demos un vistazo a una reacción
real por aquí y veamos si podemos
seguirla si esta fuera mi reacción
quiero hidrogenar este alqueno agregaría
algo de gas hidrógeno y puedo elegir
cualquier catalizador metálico que me
plazca
añadiré dos hidrógenos en el mismo
lado puedo Añadir dos hidrógenos en el
mismo lado igual que como lo hice aquí
arriba ahora obtendremos HM todo cambia
de hibridación sp2 a sp3 tenemos cuñas
y líneas de qué preocuparnos
y normalmente no lo verás dibujado así
siendo franca eso es demasiado trabajo
serí Mucho más fácil solo decir bien Lo
único que tengo que hacer es quitar el
doble enlace y ahí está mi
producto para algunas de estas
reacciones es muy muy muy fácil solo
quitas el doble enlace y terminarás con
tu producto tipo alcano HM veamos los
estados de oxidación para esta reacción
dibujaré otra vez esta reacción y esta
vez voy a dibujar mis átomos y también
dibujaré mis electrones presentes en un
segundo Solo estoy dibujando todos los
átomos Aquí tengo que preocuparme por
todos estos grupos metilo y luego tengo
electrones en estos
enlaces cada uno de estos enlaces se
componen de dos
electrones continuaré poniendo todos mis
electrones aquí
así Ahora asignemos estados de oxidación
a esos dos carbonos que formaron nuestro
doble enlace veamos el estado de
oxidación del carbono de arriba y
recuerda cuando calculas Estados de
oxidación debes preocuparte por la
electronegatividad los estados de
oxidación son pura
electronegatividad así que regresa y
mira el video anterior de Estados de
oxidación aquí comparamos las
electronegatividades del carbono y el
carbono bueno obviamente son exactamente
iguales en la pelea por estos electrones
se dividen cierto cada uno de estos
carbonos o tendrá uno de estos
electrones Ese es el caso para todos
estos de
aquí ese carbono tiene cuatro electrones
alrededor pasa Exactamente lo mismo con
este
carbono cierto este carbono tiene cuatro
electrones
alrededor para asignar un estado de
oxidación tomamos el número de
electrones de valencia que ese átomo
tiene normalmente y por su supuesto el
carbono normalmente tiene cuatro y a eso
le restamos el número de electrones que
acabamos de dibujar para nuestro
diagrama de puntos eso sería cuatro cada
uno de esos carbonos tiene cuatro cada
uno de esos carbonos tiene un estado de
oxidación de Cero y veamos el producto y
veamos si podemos asignar algunos
estados de oxidación al
producto nuestro producto aquí a la
derecha tenemos un carbono Y tenemos
algunos grupos
metilo Unidos a ese carbono agregamos un
hidrógeno Y entonces a cada uno de esos
carbonos se le añadió un
hidrógeno continuamos poniendo nuestros
electrones en estos
enlaces
nuevamente cada enlace consiste de dos
electrones así y ahora tenemos un enlace
simple entre nuestros carbonos
y asignemos algunos estados de
oxidación sabemos que los dos carbonos
tienen la misma electronegatividad
cierto así que la batalla para estos dos
electrones de aquí es un empate es es un
empate es un empate qué pasaría con el
carbono contra el hidrógeno el carbono
es de hecho más electronegativo que el
hidrógeno en la guerra por los dos
electrones en el enlace carbono
hidrógeno el carbono gana porque es un
poco más
electronegativo por lo que le
asignaremos este electrón extra al
carbono aquí y luego otra vez carbono
contra carbono por lo que ese carbono
obtiene ese electrón
también lo mismo pasa aquí abajo cierto
es un empate es un empate el carbono le
gana al hidrógeno y por aquí es un
empate en el diagrama de puntos de la
derecha los estados de oxidación el
número común de electrones de valencia
sería cuatro A eso le restamos el número
de electrones en nuestra figura aquí el
cual sería cinco electrones cada uno de
estos carbonos tiene cinco electrones
alrededor por lo que ganó un electrón y
es 4 - 5 nos dará
-1 los estados de oxidación de estos dos
carbonos son -1 y podemos ver nuestros
estados de oxidación originales siendo
cero fueron de cer0 a
a-1 ese es un decremento en el estado de
oxidación cierto un decremento en el
estado de oxidación significa una
reducción entonces Esta es una reacción
de
reción El alqueno es reducido por la
adición de estos dos
hidrógenos y verás otras definiciones
para Estados de oxidación verás que una
ganancia en hidrógenos es una reducción
esa es otra definición encontrada
regularmente en libros de texto de
química orgánica y mientras eso sea
cierto para mí tiene más sentido
continuar asignando tus estados de
oxidación y ver cambiar tus estados de
oxidación mientras tú añades esos
hidrógenos Mientras tu molécula gana
hidrógenos por lo que esto es una
reducción veamos la estereoquímica de la
reacción de
hidrogenación hagamos un ejemplo tomando
en cuenta la
estereoquímica digamos que tu alqueno se
ve algo así y reaccionará eso
con
hidrógeno y con
platino bien primero podrías pensar bien
Esto es sencillo lo único que debo hacer
es quitar
ese doble enlace Y
acabé bueno algunas veces eso es cierto
pero en este caso de hecho formamos dos
centros quirales cierto este carbono de
arriba es un centro quiral y este
carbono de abajo también es un centro
quiral algunas veces no es así de simple
debemos pensar en la adición sin de esos
hidrógenos debemos pensar en los
posibles productos que resultarían
obtendremos dos productos aquí veamos al
de la izquierda Bueno una posibilidad Es
que puedo Añadir esos dos hidrógenos en
el mismo lado como una cuña cierto tengo
un hidrógeno como una cuña y el otro
hidrógeno como una cuña esa es nuestra
adición sin Y eso significa que este
carbono de arriba este grupo etilo debe
alejándose de
mí y aquí abajo en el carbono de abajo
el grupo metilo debe de estar alejándose
de mí
así ese es un posible producto la otra
posibilidad en lugar de tener mis dos
hidrógenos como cuñas puedo tener mis
hidrógenos añadidos con líneas a trasos
ahí hay un hidrógeno y luego Aquí hay
líneas a trasos y hay un hidrógeno en
este carbono de arriba ahora mi grupo
etilo está saliendo hacia
mí y en este carbono de abajo ahora mi
grupo metilo está saliendo hacia mí
así tengo dos posibilidades Y si veo
estos dos productos puedo ver que son
enantiómeros uno es el espejo del otro
es estos dos serían mis
e
enan
te
meros estos serían los productos de mi
reacción Sé muy cuidadoso al pensar en
adiciones sin aquí hagamos un ejemplo
más de una reacción de hidrogenación
hagamos un compuesto bicí Lico puenteado
veamos si podemos dibujarlo aquí
Aquí está mi puente y luego dibujaré
esto así y luego dibujaré ese carbono de
atrás así y mi doble enlace estará aquí
y luego este será un grupo
metilo y luego aquí arriba estarán dos
grupos metilo así este es
Alfa
pineno Este es el alfa pineno encontrado
en la trementina y puedes ver que hay un
alqueno en esto si tomo esta molécula de
Alfa pineno y quiero hidrogenar la
podría usar
paladio y carbón paladio y carbono Y si
pienso en qué pasa en este mecanismo sé
que mi catalizador metálico ahí mi
paladio será plano
así y entonces cuando tiene dos
hidrógenos cuando el paladio absorbe
esos hidrógenos añadirá esos dos
hidrógenos a mi doble enlace piensa en
el alfa pineno como moléculas como una
nave espacial y la nave espacial se está
acercando a la base aeroespacial la nave
está descendiendo
lentamente la nave espacial se acercará
a la base y hay solo una manera en la
cual la nave espacial puede aproximarse
a la base y esa es la manera en la que
la hemos dibujado aquí no podría
voltearse y aproximarse desde arriba
debido al impedimento estérico de estos
grupos metilo de aquí Esta es la manera
en la que se
aproxima en esta parte de la
molécula que no es esta parte plana
cierto es mucho más fácil para la
molécula aproximarse de esta forma la
analogía de la nave espacial siempre
ayuda a mis estudiantes hay solo un
producto para esta
reacción veamos si podemos dibujarlo
aquí hay un producto para esta reacción
y veamos cómo se
vería se vería algo
así tenemos nuestros dos grupos metilo
aquí los hidrógenos se añadirán por
abajo cierto este
hidrógeno digamos que se añade aquí eso
empujará este grupo metilo hacia arriba
ese grupo metilo es empujado hacia
arriba cuando ese hidrógeno se añade
aquí abajo y luego este otro hidrógeno
se añadirá en el l opuesto Y entonces
podemos Mostrar la adición de ese
hidrógeno ahí está mi adición sí de
estos dos hidrógenos y había algo más en
ese carbono Había otro hidrógeno otro
hidrógeno fue empujado aquí arriba
también así que ese es tu único producto
el único producto de esta reacción la
reacción de hidrogenación es muy
sensible a las condiciones
esféricas